[Music]
drop what you're doing and stop
Spider-Man
Miles Morales he's entering sector four
do I uh have web on my face what's the
deal miles
black
let me guess he died
okay miles's grades are pretty good A
and AP Physics that's my little man and
AP Studio Art he takes her he takes
after his uncle a minus in English she's
a tough grader and a B in Spanish what
okay
mommy yes
I just missed a few classes oh just a
few classes well what's a few I mean you
know like
[Music]
what I already did it
look at me you
and me it's we're the same
in the important ways you know
in every other Universe Gwen Stacy Falls
for Spider-Man
[Music]
foreign
it doesn't end well
it's the first time for everything right
[Music]
my name's Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great
he's gonna be here any minute it should
be simple enough give me your money so
are you like a cow or a Dalmatian
Spider-Man
I am the spot
funny
don't do that
there's bubbles now hold on
oh in a minute I wrote it all this one
word that's cute right the youth how's
this going nice
[Music]
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
what oh okay
I gotta go all right bye
when you wanna get out of here
welcome to spider Society
Spiderman oh no way all of us are
Miguel O'Hara he's like a ninja vampire
Spider-Man but a good guy plus he's like
such a good leader
there's moments in our stories that are
the same for all of us
some good did you bring our baby to
another fight I knew I was gonna regret
making her that Webster you asked me not
to so I didn't I wouldn't
bet you have a choice between saving one
person and saving every world
that's an obvious choice send me home I
can't do that I can do both all stations
stop Spiderman
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
can this day get weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run
my name is Miles Morales
he's Spider-Man
miles wanna get out of here so wait a
minute there's an elite crew with all
the best spider people in it I'm
Spiderman oh no way all of us are being
Spider-Man
sacrifice
fate of the Multiverse you say the fate
of the Multiverse and my brain dies
Spider-Man across the spider verse
sometimes to do what's right we have to
give up the thing we want the most
the more people I try to save the more
enemies I will make
this my chance to prove myself
foreign
[Music]
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
that's not funny
don't do that
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
and I think you know it
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's been you guys this is unbelievable
this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's the guy gotta do to join
this spider team you can never be part
of this don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999
come on go easy on the kid he had a
terrible teacher Peter miles you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every word
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
everyone peace telling me how my story
is supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and then I looked at my cool ah let me
guess he died
[Music]